you
hi everyone is Jerry this is video 14
from the beginner to chess master
playlist which is a progressive series
of videos and I'd like to share with you
what it is about a pin that makes it so
powerful what is it that makes a pin in
inconvenience
I have many tips to share with you and
this one what to do when you're in a pen
what to do when your opponent is in a
pin things you ought to be thinking
about in those situations and also and
maybe most importantly I'd like you to
take away from this video a deeper
understanding of the pin a more general
view of the pin I have many examples to
share with you this first one that I'm
putting on board is likely a chess
players first experience with the pin or
in other words where a bishop is
developed and does what pins a knight to
the Queen or is developed and pins a
knight to the king this is a popular
situation most players have experience
with some special attention ought to be
given here this is not the only example
but it's a popular one I will be
devoting some extra attention to this
situation so where to begin what exactly
is going on when there is a pin present
on board who's involved when there is a
pin present in
in position at least three pieces are
involved we have the pinning piece the
white bishop in this case we have the
pinned piece the Black Knight and we
have the black queen who as we say the
knight is pinned to this is one way to
view it the pinning piece the pinned
piece and the piece that the knight is
pinned to the knight is pinned why
exactly well there's a serious negative
consequence connected with his movement
if he moves we get the Queen how might
we describe better these three pieces
your internal dialogue in AD just as a
player developing a good internal
dialogue is a big deal
so these aren't just some random
identifiers I'm going to be sharing with
you as I discussed this pin subject I
thought some about what words to choose
what I think will be most helpful for
you as a developing player and it
basically runs as follows here's one
take you can have in these situations
you can identify the bishop as a free
piece a piece who does not have any
restriction placed on him he can go
wherever he wants he does not have any
responsibilities the knight
unfortunately he is not free he is
restricted he can't move
he should not move the Queen as
well is restricted she has a job and a
very important one and that is to keep a
watchful eye over the night a very quick
tip is when you're in a pin you should
look to get out of the pin seems very
basic right it's an uncomfortable
situation when you're in a pin it's not
just one piece who is restricted but two
we have this free piece the bishop who
is restricting to black pieces the
knight can't move in the Queen she can't
get out of this pin so easily black
can't at this stage say you know what
pins are uncomfortable I would really
like to be able to move by night
therefore I'll just get out of the pin
like so not so fast as this would allow
Bishop takes Knight and after black
recaptures what has just happened
black created four holes in their
position four holes near their king
black is crazy to allow this
they've just damaged their Kings home
their most important piece his shelter
has been damaged considerably this is
not a good way to get out of a pin it's
an uncomfortable situation without
question for black
how might black get out of this pin in a
better way
here's one approach which is to ask the
bishop a question attack the bishop with
the pawn are you going to take the
knight or not this right here is
something black would really like to see
a quick tip is when you have your
opponent in a pin don't take the pinned
piece don't be so quick
to take pinch pieces why is this the
case
well the bishop has been exchanged this
free piece this is a way to view it this
free piece has been exchanged for a
restricted piece but not only that the
queen who was restricted is now free she
no longer after the smoke clears after
the bishop for a night exchange occurs
this queen is now free she doesn't have
a job of watching over a restricted
piece any longer so by capturing a
pinned piece you're really helping your
opponent out that should not be your
first thought when you have your
opponent in a pin to take the pinned
piece but rather how can I further
attack the pinned piece should be that's
a better frame of mind to be in it's a
better thought process to run through
first and foremost how can I attack this
pinned piece further should it really be
a question running through White's mind
how to maybe attack the piece who is
defending the pinned piece how can you
maybe chase the Queen away from
defending the knight those thoughts
right there should come before you even
consider taking the pinned piece and
alleviating your opponent of their
restricted position you could question
the bishops position like this with h6
this is not a bad move if white is aware
that capturing the knight would only be
helpful to black they may say to
themselves well I'll just get out of the
pawns way and do what keep the pin via
pest pins or pain but how far do you
take this black at this stage can and I
will
it cannot emphasize this enough I would
be extra cautious about doing this next
move black can play g5 and this is a way
to break the pin it is true that the
knight is now free to move the pawn is
throwing a punch at the bishop he has to
run away and there is no longer a pin
great right well not all is well and
good here for black because they've
created for weaknesses by playing this
g5 move they've created four holes near
their King there are other approaches to
dealing with the pin one approach is to
simply not weaken your King position and
this would be my suggestion at least in
this specific example right here instead
of making a move like g5 simply
returning the bishop like so to break
the pin and not weakening your King
position would be a better approach I
know
again I'm spending some extra attention
to this one but it's important to
recognize at the very least a couple
ways you can try to get out of a pin you
can think about g5 mmm there's some
serious weaknesses when you do that you
can also think about breaking the pin
Bishop to e7 in this case this pin
against the Queen Knight is usually
extremely the pin against the king
Knight the pin of the knight to the
Queen is usually the more disruptive of
the two pins I started out saying that
there's the pin of the the knight to the
Queen and also the pin of a knight to
the king
the one where you are pinning the night
to the king for example if this happened
in let's just say black plays d6 okay
the knight is pinned to the king this
really isn't that great of an issue
because let's just say after d3 black
develops white castles how do you get
out of a pin in this case you could
simply Castle it's true that white can
capture the knight like this and we have
a case of doubled pawns this really
isn't so much of an issue
not nearly as great an issue as it would
be if the doubling of the pawns occurred
on this side of the board the black King
does not reside over here having a
damaged Queen side structure the King
isn't located over there it's not his
home so this isn't so much of an issue
it's a much different story if you had
those doubled F pawns so you could my
main point here is that you could simply
get out of the pin by castling if your
knight is pinned to the king if we have
this exchange okay there's the little
trade off damage structure for black but
black has an extra bishop and the bishop
has a tendency to be a little bit more
valuable than a knight okay is there
anything more I really want to share
from this example I don't believe so I
think we could go into some more I'd
like to quickly point out one other way
you can look to break a pin and it comes
about like so just want to give you a
little bit of a feel for how to get out
of a pin
so for example in this case here you
could look to do something like this
where your Knights are now connected
notice the bishop is pinning the knight
to the Queen why can connect nights like
this and then simply move the Queen out
of the pin and what is this doing it's
freeing up the knight to move if he's
captured now we don't have to take with
the pawn and damage our structure I'd
simply recapture with the other night
I'm just trying to give a little quick
little way a quick little tip as to how
you can get out of a pin let me return
for a moment to this first example this
is something that's important I forgot
to mention this and that is you may you
know with this talk of well the pin it's
inconvenient how about I just stop the
pin from even showing up altogether so
for example after the move d3 instead of
castles here suppose black says well if
I Castle the bishop is going to play
here let me play h6
it's true that you could do that
although keep in mind this is not a
developing move
keep in mind what you ought to be doing
in the opening developing your pieces
getting castled this is not a developing
move it is a strictly defensive move
against this not one that I would really
recommend but I could see that as being
a mentality a chess player has you know
I could see I could see a player
experiencing something really bad
happening to them with a pin like after
Bishop g5 of d6 Knight d5 what is this
doing it's piling up on the pinned piece
what's like doing they recognize the pin
they're now adding more pieces to it
this is a good strategy if black now
does something like h6 this is just bad
at this point it's no good for black why
we have Knight takes Knight pawn takes
Bishop takes I believe most players
probably experience something like this
as well the loss of upon the damaged
King side structure from this experience
I could see many players say to
themselves you know what I know how to
stop this all together I'm just not even
going to allow the pin to take place
instead of castles after d3 I'm going to
play each six huh you're just not going
to play to g5 and pin me at all
recognize what you're doing you are
preventing the pin that is true this is
not a bad move in the computers eyes
this is fine in this situation however I
would certainly look more into
developing your pieces dealing dealing
with the pin maybe taking a more
conservative approach with your Bishop
instead of playing it out to c5 maybe a
more modest move like Bishop to e7
anticipating the pin and developing not
wasting this valuable tempo to
prevent Bishop g5 these are other things
to be considering there's a lot more I
could be sharing on this but I just want
to give you a rough feel here in this in
this position type where the bishop is
too developed in pinning the knight to
the Queen okay I don't think I'll be
revisiting this example again but I
think that's now everything I wanted to
cover on that one okay
with these next four examples have some
pop quizzes here I will not be spending
nearly as much time on each of these
examples as I did with this first one
here but let's have a look at this one
as a start playing as team black White's
next move is Queen to d4 what should
black do if you'd like to go ahead pause
the video see what move you would play
as black okay the best move here is not
to capture the pinned piece but rather
attack it this is the frame of mind you
should be in when you see a pin can I
attack the pinned piece or can i attack
the the King in this case notice the
three pieces that are involved in this
situation we have the pinning piece the
Queen the black queen
the pinned piece the Queen the White
Queen and the piece that the White Queen
is pinned to the King we should be
looking to disrupt the white Queens
position somehow or maybe even the Kings
position playing rook to d7 is the best
move attacks the Queen and what does she
do after Queen takes Queen we capture
the rook with check and then scoop up
the Queen and black is going to win the
main point of emphasis here is that when
we have our opponent in a pin look to
attack the pinned piece and the piece
that the in this case the piece that the
Queen is pinned to the King look to
attack one of these two instead of
capturing the pinned piece
note the note the difference there we're
now looking to capture the pinned piece
but rather attack it further let's have
a look at another example this one right
here once again playing as black lights
last move on to a3 what should we do
here let's point out where there is a
pin here's where we have a pin the
knight is pinned to the Queen we should
not be looking to first capture the
pinned piece but rather attack it
further what would be a good move in
this position if you'd like to pause the
video see what the best move is here for
white excuse me see what the best move
is here for black okay the best move
here is to do what attack that pinned
piece further on e4 the knight is
attacked and he's going to be captured
next if he moves we get the Queen if
pawn to h3 trying to chase the bishop
away while this isn't working we could
just take like this that's one way to do
it
pawn takes Bishop pawn takes Bishop
black is winning material with that
sequence of moves we should be looking
first to attack the pinned piece further
instead of capturing the pinned piece
recognize the restricted nature the
restricted position that white is in the
knight can't move the Queen has a
certain responsibility to watching over
the knight look to attack the pinned
piece let's have a look at another one
this one right here where it is white to
move if you'd like to go ahead pause the
video see what move you would play in
this position okay this is our third
example we have one more after this
related to this mentality of looking to
attack the pinned piece or the defender
of the pinned piece best move in this
case is to take on b2
not take the Queen if you take the Queen
black simply recaptures we're not taking
in each of these first three examples we
are never capturing the pinned piece
we're doing something else we're looking
to attack the pinched puppies further or
do something to the defending piece in
this case we could take a free piece
Bishop takes Bishop there is no Queen
takes bishop she is pinned to the king
Queen takes Queen Knight takes at the
end white is now up a minor piece let's
have a look at one more example once
again this is a black to move after
Queen to b4 let me make one black move
here Queen D one check white only has
one reply now what to do let me also
point out you know in this example where
black comes down and gives check when
your opponent is in check if they are
not making a king move and yeah if they
don't make a king move if they're not
getting out of check and if they are not
capturing the checking piece if they're
not capturing the checking piece so
they're doing something other then
moving the King or capturing the
checking piece such as playing Queen to
e1 the only legal move here they are
doing what's called working themselves
into a pin so you should you know just
as soon as you see if you're playing
over the board or something if you're if
you have your opponent in check and
they're ready to pick up another piece
and block the check they are immediately
doing what they're working themselves
into a pin how can you take advantage of
this
how can you maybe look to attack the
Queen position further or even the king
you can do that with Bishop to a6 that
gives a check
white only has one legal move the Queen
cannot block she is pinned to the King
Knight has to block and what do we do we
don't take the pin piece but rather
Bishop takes Knight King cannot take
that would be check Queen cannot take
she's pinned King has to play here and
what happens next now we take the pin
fees when nothing I'm not saying that we
never take a pin piece in this case hey
we're winning a free piece but not only
that we're giving checkmate in this case
in each of those four examples they just
shared with you we were never doing what
we were never thinking first to take the
pinned piece we were looking to attack
it further we were looking to disrupt a
defending piece of the pinned piece like
this right here we're looking to disrupt
the defender of the Queen in this case
with Bishop to a6 okay I have just three
more examples to share with you and I'd
like to make a suggestion regarding the
vocabulary we use so far I've been using
the term pin a real lot but I would like
you to view it in a different way
instead of viewing it as a pinned piece
I think we would be much better off as a
chess player we would be much better off
in our much better off with our internal
dialogue as viewing a pin as a form of
restriction in chess view a pinned piece
as
viewing a pinned piece as a restricted
piece I think will serve you well when
playing
why is this the case we're going to see
in this position it's white to move if
you'd like to pause the video see what
movie would play okay
the move here is Bishop to d5 pins the
rook to the king it restricts the rook
King up seven now what when you have
your opponent restricted you should not
be so quick to alleviate that situation
not be so quick to take the pin piece
don't be so quick to release the
restricted if you take the rook you're
helping the King to now approach this
pawn he'll be able to track him down
white can win this position for as long
as they are not so quick to release the
restricted pieces the rook is clearly
restricted and the King is also
restricted he has a responsibility to
watch over the rook the best move in
this position is to simply push your
pawn now after black only gets out of
the pin at this stage now we take the
rook King takes bishop we push the pun
and we're going to Queen
and if black does something else like
approaches the pawn at this stage right
here let's say after Bishop takes rook
King here well this will still be a win
for white the bishop is defending the
pawn soon the King comes over to help
and then finally pushes through it's not
the most important point this end part
of this puzzle the main point here is to
recognize the restricted piece the rook
in this case and not be so quick to take
the restricted piece don't be so quick
to release the restricted pieces pushing
your pawn here white will go on to win
exercise a little patience in the game
recognize these situations it's
important there will be plenty of other
situations where there is restricted
environments in a chess game you should
be looking to identify them and exercise
some patience not be so quick to release
the restricted pieces to free them up to
do some other tasks let's have a look at
one more light to move in this position
if you'd like to go ahead pause the
video see if you can find the best move
here for white okay the best move here
for white is to play rook to c6 and this
is a rarity I would say you're not going
to see situations like this so much we
have with this last move white doing
what restricting the knight the knight
is pinned to the king it's a very very
uncomfortable situation for black so
much so that they are not only in this
this restricted state but they simply
cannot get out of it how do you get out
of the pin how do you get out of this
restricted situation you go here your
another uncomfortable position this is a
really simple win for white for as long
as they are not so quick to release this
restricted position the for as long as
they are not so quick to release the
restricted environment black is in after
rook c6 what does black do King here
here's a very clean way to approach this
simply push the pawn never take the
knight unless he's going to be free if
you take him right away this is not such
a good idea because this King will be
able to hunt down this pawn and yeah
we've actually already experienced we've
already seen a position like this very
not sure which one it was I think video
10 black has a case of what protected
past pawn that's a big deal black will
go on to win this position the main
point here is to keep your opponent
bottled up recognize that there's no way
to even get out of this situation keep
the pin push the pawn and you could
actually just keep pushing what does
black do to pieces in this case are
doing what restricting three let's have
a look at one more last one right here
white to move if you'd like to go ahead
pause the video see what move actually
let me take it one further think two to
three moves ahead with this one a white
move a black move a white move what
would you do like to move in this one
okay best move for white is Knight to d7
that's a check so pretty big fork two
rooks or hit King is hit after King 2d
for now what what are you doing next
which rook are you going to take
hopefully neither if you take either
rook White will lose this and this is
this is the big reason why I wanted to
present this in a way where you view it
as pieces being restricted not as a pen
there are plenty of examples where there
is a restricted environment in a chess
game this is one of them this isn't a
pin this isn't a form of a pin but this
is a situation where black is restricted
how well this rook has a responsibility
on b8
he is restricted what is his job its
defend the rook on f8
what is this rooks job it's to do
similar and defend the rook on b8 both
rooks are restricted if you capture
either one of them you're helping black
out you should wait for one of the black
rooks to make a move in this case and
only then make a capture recognize that
they're not going anywhere and in the
meantime how can white do better how
could they improve their position by
exercising some patience in this case is
white here's something better you can
push your pawn and now if this rook gets
out of the way from capture only at this
point do we take this rook and after the
recapture we play here and we're soon
going to get a new Queen if you are
capturing the rook right away in this
case instead of this best move pawn to
h7 for capturing the rook black
recaptures push now he gets over here
just in time
and you're not going to be so quick to
Queen in fact light will go on to now
lose this is an extreme case this last
example here that I'm sharing with you
this is an extreme case of you a
position where you have your opponent
restricted do not be so quick to take
restricted pieces is my main point the
difference can be a win or a loss if
you're taking your restricted piece in
this case white will go on to lose this
position if you are exercising some
patience and doing something other
recognize the restricted position that
black is in doing something like h7
light will go on to win be patient
recognize these restricted environments
in a chess game and if I'm to make a
promise I know that you will be a much
better chess player recognizing these
situations and really being attentive to
finding better moves in the position
such as this h7 advanced recognizing
that neither rook is going nowhere only
when one moves should you even consider
taking a rook in this case do something
else
try to find something better in the
meantime you are improving as a chess
player recognizing situations like this
where your opponent is restricted
okay believe that is everything that I
wanted to cover with this one as usual I
hope you got something out of it and we
will see what is in store for video 15
that's all for now take care bye
you